I don’t want an app, so I’m a green parish, so I
want to buy SARS First of all,
lv22 resident lord h timing is
xe2 nak ah exr power principal switch ah ying bae wolju
[music]
1 4 oshu people like this
I will put it well, the
elder Will Kochu sees what we do. Our dance is
really delicious, and Seoyoung’s alcohol is
a lyricist sws. My name is Seo Youngsoo, Niyoyo, I am
a person who contains the flavor
of
Gochujang Gochujang is a silver food that Koreans need
. It is an indispensable
food.
These days gets to resolve
tanning pair watch Pajeon contains very strong
veloster 3 poland naan with
red pepper paste 0 First,
glutinous rice and malt to swallow glutinous rice
are added, and each week reluctance to flavor it, and seasoned
sea salt  Yes, it goes in and goes in.
Yes,
because of the aging of this kind of soybean paste for 8 months or more, the taste of red pepper paste comes out a little
.
The joy of being born is delicious and it is hidden, but it must be known,
it is sharp, the product is delicious,
and it has a deeper taste.
The
new generation don't know what to put with flowers
because they are accustomed to buying and eating
, but I have experienced and
learned how to put red pepper paste
in it.
I'm telling you to eat, because
Korea's tradition can't disappear.